quando torni a casa la sera e vuoi fare
due coccole colto fidanzato matteo
fidanzato è così amore mandami vicini
insegnando a fare i baci alla vittoria
secret angel servi così la vittoria si
che cosa cazzo dici o mi mandi baci il
mondo wetransfer d'amore
no non parla la tua lingua iman di baci
ma non i vaccini suonate a tutti che
come volevasi dimostrare non aspettavate
altro che io parlassi di voi highline
stambecchi milano after two howard zinn
cremona hanoun dai tic tic quindi fate
però il de bonis e bianchi e sti casi se
vuoi al numero chiama and my outfit for
tonight è la rizzo marce lizza making ma
che cazzo di male ti sei messo
alberta baby alberta ferretti
buonanotte raviolo ora violo ma non ti
sembra aver dimenticato qualcosa ma no
pacchettino li abbiamo fatti lista
stories prima di andare a dormire
tranquillo ma no non lista stories
proprio qualcosa o ma dove cazzo
l'abbiamo masturbarsi
[Musica]